[Musik]
herzlich willkommen ja genau zehn jahre
ist es her seit der nuklearkatastrophe
von fukushima wie riskant ist die
kernenergie heute und wie steht es um
die alternativen wie sollen wir
vernünftig mit risiken umgehen als
einzelne aber auch aus gesellschaft etwa
im umgang mit cookies 19 und der frage
ob wir uns impfen lassen sollen oder
nicht darüber rede ich jetzt mit der
promovierten physikerin und philosophin
rafaela hillerbrand sie ist professorin
für technik tätig und
wissenschaftstheorie am karlsruher
institut für technologie herzlich
willkommen frau hellerbrand ja welche
risiken haben sie dann in kauf genommen
um hierherzukommen er die sendung ja
vielleicht ein erhöhtes infektionsrisiko
dadurch dass ich mit den öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln angereist bin
das hielt sich glaube ich in grenzen die
bahn ist noch relativ leer
ich bin relativ früh losgefahren da
merkte man dass die straßenbahnen doch
sehr voll sind da merkt man auch dass
coop 19 infektionsrisiko auch eine sache
von sozialen status ist denn die leute
die vor sechs uhr in die straßenbahn
steigen haben wahrscheinlich eher am
unteren ende des spektrums sind und sich
damit größeren risiken aussetzen als
leute wie ich die ganz einfach im
home-office setzen können sie
beschäftigen sich schon seit vielen
jahren intensiv mit fragen des risikos
mit der ethik des risikos im umgang hat
sie das eigentlich eher risikoscheu
gemacht oder risikofreudig ich glaube
das kann ich so gar nicht beantworten
ich glaube ich bin von natur er eine
risikoaverse person risikoscheu
ich glaub was es mir geholfen hat es mit
unsicherheiten umzugehen und ich
informiere mich immer gerne verbreitet
das ist mir zweimal bei impfungen
aufgefallen und ich kann dann auch ich
gehe lieber mit ungewissen ausgängen um
als dass ich das gefühl hat mir wird
informationen verschwiegen
meine tochter ist für sie ist komplett
geimpft aber wir wohnen in den
niederlanden und in deutschland und
haben sie in den niederlanden impfen
lassen das war damals ja unser
hauptwohnsitz und da wurde man bei der
ersten impfung wirklich abgefragt er
wissen sie was die impfnebenwirkungen
sein können mag bekam der telefonnummer
mit wenn sie nicht aufgelistet
impfnebenwirkungen sehen rufen sie
darunter anwenden sie sich da und da hin
und als ich mich wenn ich mich in
deutschland impfen lass und meine
tochter in deutschland impfen lasse und
ich frage nach möglichen nebenwirkungen
ein nein gibt es keine und das macht
mich traurig wenn man nicht gut
informiert ist ja genau das ist ja
einfach so wir wissen lang
langzeitfolgen können wir nicht mit
sicherheit vorhersagen und damit können
wir dann umgehen aber wenn man das
ignoriert
ich hatte auch an viele lokalpolitiker
jetzt mit 19 jahren impfungen reden es
gibt keine nebenwirkungen natürlich sind
das klinische tests die gemacht wurden
nach besten wissen und gewissen und
standard der wissenschaft heute aber die
langzeitfolgen die kommen nicht absagen
ab vorhersagen und präsident der welt
ärzte das weit ärzte bund dass man komme
ich sagte ja alle alles über die
langzeitfolgen ist spekulation und das
beruhigt mich dann wieder und genau dann
dass ich mich impfen sogar mit der
information oder mit dem
nichtvorhandensein derselben umgeht als
ein transparent umgehen mit unsicherheit
und dann haben sie auch sozusagen den
mut auf ihr bauchgefühl zu hören wenn
sie sozusagen sich gut informiert haben
und wissen es besteht diese unsicherheit
dann können sie das risiko eingehen ja
dann bauchgefühl wäre ich vorsichtig das
bauchgefühl ist wichtig als indikator da
kann was schief gehen aber ich glaube
wenn man die zeit hat eine entscheidung
zu nehmen dann ist das bauchgefühl ein
erster indikator aber sollte nicht der
grund sein für eine entscheiden sondern
der ausgangspunkt wenn man sich dann
weiter informiert sollte man sich in
bestimmten fällen auch gegen das
bauchgefühl entscheiden welchen gründen
es sind immer abwägung
ich habe den eindruck wir blenden im
alltag auch viele risiken heraus also
wenn wir das auto nehmen auf die straße
gehen oder uns so oder so ernähren ist
das eigentlich gut gewählt bestimmte
risiken auszublenden oder ist das naiv
sollte man sich irgendwie so gut wie
möglich immer informieren
also ich glaube das sind natürlich
irgendwie pragmatische grenzen gesetzt
dem so gut wie möglich immer informieren
aber ich glaube man sollte eine gewisse
art von rationalität und seinem risiko
herangehensweise haben also jetzt zum
beispiel von staatlicher ebene
wir wussten oder es gab szenarien für
eine saas kopf zwei erkrankung am außen
jahre 2012 gibt es einer studie der
deutschen bundes und auftrag der
deutschen bundesregierung in der beinahe
die blaupause für 2020 zu lesen ist was
2020 passiert mit der ausbreitung des
virus und auch seinen ausgangspunkt in
china vielleicht mit ein und hat zwei
monaten versetzt also deutlich später
ins studium und es wird angegeben dass
das mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit von
einmal im jahrhundert bis einmal mehr
1000 auftritt also relativ oft und wenn
man das dann gegenüberstellt dass man
sagt ein klares endlage muss haben eine
millionen jahre sicher sein denn dann
ist da zumindest irgendwie vorsicht zu
verhalten das eine ist natürlich ja
nicht ganz ein naturereignis natürlich
auch die ausbreitung dieses virus
menschen gemacht ist auf eine gewisse
art und weise durch die zu losen aber
und technische ressourcen an das
technische risiken müssen anders
behandelt werden
aber gleichzeitig stimmt da irgendwas
nicht wen wir rational und so wir
wussten schon acht jahre lang kann man
sagen das ist die wahrscheinlichkeit ein
ziemlich hoch ist dass uns sowas etwas
mal passieren wird in als einmal in
hundert jahren oder einmal 1000 ja dass
das relativ häufig
das wäre ein guter grund gewesen viel
bessere vorkehrungen zu treffen
jetzt wird man aber auch immer oft so
eine zeit diagnose über unsere
gesellschaft das ist ein nullrisiko
gesellschaft also auf den skipisten in
der schweiz tragen alle helme die kinder
sind auf dem kindersitz angegurtet im
auto ist eine vollkaskomentalität hört
man auch würden sie dem zustimmen dass
so die die risikoscheu die des
sicherheitsbedürfnisses zugenommen hat
in der gesamtgesellschaft ich denke
schon ich glaube dass das ja auch ein
ausdruck von wohlstand und was wir mit
fortschritt assoziieren
natürlich kann ich sagen die kinder
haben vor 20 jahren keine
getragen oder vor 40 und auch groß
geworden aber die kindersterblichkeit
war deutlich höher und das gleiche gilt
für coop 19 klar natürlich betrifft
hauptsächlich die menschen über 70 aber
wir assoziieren das mit fortschritt dass
wir bei gesunder bei gesundheit länger
leben können man darf es nicht so ganz
das kind mit dem bade ausschütten ich
hatte einen kollegen john adams in
england so wunderschön illustrierte
england ist in vieler hinsicht in den
kleinen dingen sehr risikoavers in
meiner wahrnehmung und er hatte das
beispiel vom kinderspielplatz da wurde
erstmal der sand entfernt mit
plastischer setzten weil es besser nach
dann wurden die die schau kann ersetzt
weil man könnte sicher darin verheddern
und dann ist es waren keine kinder mehr
auf dem kinderspielplatz was ihr
natürlich super sicher machte und auch
nutzen wenn man sozusagen das
sicherheitsbedürfnis sicherheit ganz
hoch steigert maximiert dann wir das
lebensfeindlich und die leute können die
sich überhaupt nicht oder wollen sich
nicht mehr darauf haben jetzt sie haben
uns schon gesagt sie sind mit dem zug
angereist aus karlsruhe muss ich
arbeiten am karlsruher institut für
technologie als professor in dieser zug
diese strecke diese partie natürlich
strom und ein großteil des stroms stammt
natürlich sowohl in der schweiz als auch
in deutschland immer noch aus
kernkraftwerken und die sind unfall
anfällig wie wir das wie ich das gesagt
haben vor zehn jahren
dieses diese katastrophe in fukushima
das war am 11 märz 2011 da erschüttert
ein seebeben der stärke 9 japan und
löste an der ostküste bis zu 15 meter
hohen tsunami werden aus die weite
landstriche zerstört 20.000 menschen
starben dabei im kernkraftwerk fukushima
kam es zu einer nuklearen katastrophe zu
einer kernschmelze in den reaktoren
es trat radioaktivität aus welche die
ganze umgebung verstrahlte und rund
160.000 personen mussten die gegend
verlassen
ja was hat denn die welt aus diesem
schrecklichen ereignis gelernt ich
glaube es ist viel passiert in der folge
von fukushima und ich glaube wenn man
nochmal des zehnjährigen jubiläums revue
passiert aber es war gut sich noch mal
auf die konkreten freuen
sie hatten sich ja gerade schon teilen
gesagt in fukushima kam es zu
kernschmelzen den drei laufenden
reaktoren und vorgelassen wurde viel
radioaktivität frei vor allem dann auch
über den pazifik getragen hat sich gut
weltweit verteilt aber zwar noch
oberhalb der nachweisgrenze zum beispiel
in deutschland aber nicht mehr
gesundheit steht ich das natürlich eine
andere sache für die es vor ort und es
kam in der folge der evakuierung der
gebiete zu über 2000 todesfällen vor
allem unter älteren und schon kranken
menschen kann man einfach man muss sich
das vorstellen das war nicht nur
nuklearkatastrophe das war wie sie ja
gesagt eine nuklearkatastrophe in einem
erdbebengebiet
und man hat bei der überquerung sehr
viele fehler gemacht zum beispiel es
wirklich ganz dramatisch in einem bus
mit älteren leuten einfach irgendwohin
geschoben außerhalb der strahlengefahr
aber vergessen und es kam so zu über
2.000 leute zu tode deutlich überhalb
der in dem gebiet der vorherrschenden
tode direkt durch den tsunami das
erdbeben unmittelbare strahlentod gibt
es einen einen der arbeiter hat auch
entschädigung gekriegt mittlerweile von
lungenkrebs verstorbenen die familie
bekam entschädigung auch hat durch die
den japanischen staat und die
schätzungen steuerstreit
da sind wir im bereich risiken
unsicherheiten hundertprozentig
nachvollziehen kann man natürlich so
strahlend roten echten immer mit
bestimmten plausibilitäten und momentan
gehen die schätzungen sehr auseinander
der wissenschaft was anstrahlen toten
erwartet wird das geht von null bis gut
wir haben jetzt schon einen also von
sehr wenig bis der einige hunderte
deutschland eine große folge war der
ausstieg aus der kernenergie also ich
hoffe nicht dass das die lesson learned
war hoffentlich nicht dass die
kernenergie riskantes ich hoffe das
wussten alle vorher die sich dafür
entschieden haben
man ist ausgestiegen also bis 2023 gehen
bei uns auch noch die verbleibenden drei
meiler am netz
weltweit sieht der trend anders aus also
man hat immer noch über 400 laufende
kernkraftwerke 200 in planung ungefähr
50 im bau was ich sicher geändert hat
ist die ökonomischen kosten für die
kleinen gehen nicht nur durch fukushima
aber auch natürlich die
sicherheitskonzepte andere sind das in
england ist jetzt ein in der
planungsphase gewesen das kraftwerk
wahrscheinlich gestoppt aufgrund der
ökonomischen kosten in mühlburg ging ja
auch vom netz das man sich nur 110 in
der schweiz aus ökonomischen gründen was
sich auch geändert hat ist glaube ich
die ganze haltung zur energiepolitik ich
glaube man hat ethik energie ethik
überhaupt als fach- und als
notwendigkeit entdeckt das war natürlich
nicht nur fukushima sondern auch die
folgen der klimaerwärmung werden
natürlich immer deutlicher aber
fukushima hat auch schon viel dazu
beigetragen ich glaube wenn es irgendwas
gutes aus dieser aus diesem unglück gibt
dann vielleicht dass energie techniken
oder vielleicht jede komplexe technisch
nicht einfach schwarz weiß ist sondern
wir befinden uns da in der moralischen
oder ethischen bewertung in graubereiche
und können auch schlecht abschließend
sagen auf jeden fall gehört kernenergie
zu den bösen techniken gehört immer
verboten oder eben auch nicht
aber neben diesem unfallrisiko besteht
das problem der endlagerung das immer
wieder betont wird
wie steht man denn als risiko ethischer
sich zu diesem problem sie haben gesagt
eine million jahre liegen diese
brennstäbe später bin ich aber so ein
schönes beispiel also ein teil der
risiken kommt ja vor allem aus dem
schreiben
entscheidung stehe und die befasst sich
damit wie gehe ich mit unsicherheiten um
und wenn es jetzt um die
wahrscheinlichkeit eines ungeheuers geht
dann können wir glaube ich wirklich gut
sagen das bin entscheidung unter risiko
haben wir können vielleicht mit
wahrscheinlichkeiten im sinne von
relativen häufigkeiten ich tests sind
mein material angeben wie häufig mein
ventil bricht in den nächsten zehn
jahren
ich kann da relativ häufigkeiten
wahrscheinlichkeiten angeben aber wenn
es jetzt darum geht ob dieses diese
gestalt tiefe
logische gesteinsformation die nächsten
die nächsten eine millionen jahre das
ist das was die deutsche bundesregierung
fordert für die stabilität einer
gesteinsformation führen entlang oder
nur 24.000 jahre halbwertszeit von
plutonium stabil ist ja dann können wir
keine häufigkeit relative häufigkeit
mehr angeben weil ich erfahrung fehlt
für social großen zeiträume genau also
wir können das ja einfach nicht durch
mehr ist und man kann immer noch
schätzungen machen man kann vielleicht
ja sagen ich glaube das ist stabil mit
einer bestimmten wahrscheinlichkeit muss
erst mal was anderes und damit muss man
auch anders umgehen als mit diesen
risiken im engeren sinn also ich weiß
mit welcher wahrscheinlichkeit was
auftritt oder mit den unsicherheiten wo
ich zwar ungefähr weiß was passieren
kann
wir haben glaube ich ein gutes
verständnis davon was passiert wenn
größere mengen radioaktive strahlung
frei werden weil wir es ja auch schon
ein paar mal gesehen haben nicht nur
fukushima und tschernobyl und so weiter
aber man muss die ganz unterschiedlich
angehen dann gibt es noch den anderen
fall den wir auch ganz auf den der
technik haben was wir gar nicht mehr
wissen was alles passieren könnte
und das sind so im deutschen
entscheidungen und ungewissheit im
englischen irgendwann wird es bildet
noch ein bisschen besser ab oder am
donald rumsfeld hat mal vor ein paar
jahren den begriff der anderen an uns
geprägt also wirklich dieses es passiert
etwas was wir überhaupt nicht auf dem
schirm hatten und die technik das
erkenne ich natürlich erst im nachhinein
die werke dann kann ich das beispiel aus
der geschichte und eine
technikgeschichte hält erhält ein paar
beispiele vor eins davon ist die
markteinführung von fckw ist die wurden
ja als formel 1 ab den 70er jahren als
exzellente kühlmittel vor allem
gebraucht und waren in erdgas also in
hartegasse gas verdient erst mal nicht
reagieren und dann abzusehen dass sie in
der atmosphäre bei für kühleren
temperaturen wo man eigentlich aber als
etwas weniger reaktion auftritt diese
ozon schädigende wirkung entfalten wird
gern als beispiel gebracht etwas was
sich im nachhinein als entscheidung
unter 1 heraus das heißt es gibt wie es
gibt nicht einfach risiko es gibt drei
arten könnte man vielleicht sagen das
risiko im engeren sind da kennt man
ungefähr die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
etwas passiert
hat dann gibt es diese ungewissheit oder
unsicherheit wie sie das gesagt haben da
kann man nicht mal die
wahrscheinlichkeiten angeben und man
weiß was die gefahr ist
und dann dieses dritte diese anlagen an
uns diese komplette unwissenheit wo man
nicht mal an geben kann was sage ich das
schlecht ist oder dass gefahren szene
haben ja nicht mal nicht mal kennt genau
das ist schlimmer ist natürlich weiter
ich meine entscheidungs horizont
ahrweiler sie weiter ich mir anschaue
welche folgen eine handlung in der
zukunft hat stichwort nukleares endlager
eine millionen jahr oder nur 1000 jahre
und je globaler ich meine entscheidungen
betrachtest du eher bin ich natürlich in
der entscheidung unter uns unter
ungewissheit und wie ich meine
entscheidungs horizont das was ich noch
mit rein rechne in meine entscheidung
abschneiden ist natürlich auch eine
genetische frage wo wir überhaupt keine
hilfsmittel zur verfügung haben aber das
interessiert mich jetzt auf welche
prinzipien stützt man sich also wenn wir
uns jetzt eine neue technologie
entwickelt wo man irgendwie so ein paar
risiken vielleicht im voraus oder
wahrscheinlichkeiten für gefahren
berechnen kann aber viel das einfach
auch noch offen ist also ich denke noch
zurück an die handys war dann über die
handystrahlung in vivo man sich ängste
gemacht hat an gentechnik und solche
sachen wie geht man da risiko ethisch um
etwas stützt man sich gibt es
irgendwelche prinzipien daran die man
sich halten kann
ja ich glaube ganz gut kann man das sind
zwei sehr diametral entgegengesetzten
prinzipien klar macht dass eines
risikominimierung das kennen wir auch
aus unserer alltagsentscheidungen mache
die handlung die am wenigsten im schnitt
am wenigsten risiko erwartet aber da
gehe ich davon aus dass sich das risiko
kennen im sinne von schaden mal
eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit so kann ich
kernkraftwerke für ihren gebrauch
auslegen aber für all diese entscheidung
unter ungewissheit wo ich keine
wahrscheinlichkeit an kamen im engeren
sinn habe oder auch glaube ich habe noch
nicht einmal verlässliche subjektive
wahrscheinlichkeiten das so selbst wenn
ich sage ich glaube dass das mit 90
prozent wahrscheinlichkeit ist und ich
glaube ich kann das schon nicht mehr
ordentlich systemische untermauern
kennt man völlig diametral
entgegengesetzt das
entscheidungskriterium das
vorsorgeprinzip
risikominimierung was im endeffekt schau
dir gefahren an
aber auch den nutzen so soll das
gesamtpaket das wäre ideal also bei der
auslegung von technik und auch ganz oft
in der medizin schraubt fokussiert man
nur auf den negativen ausgang ideal wäre
natürlich das wird der technik-check
auch oft vorgeworfen dass man den
positiven effekt eine technologie mit
nicht mit einbezieht dann müsste man das
würde man dann im deutschen erwartungs
nutzen theorie nennen das man halt
einfach ganz klassisch utilitaristische
also man maximiert den nicht nutzen
die mosley tourismus um den erwarteten
nutzen der mittel erwarteten nutzen
genau aber da brauche ich ja irgendwas
was mir das mittel angeht was ich
brauche eine wahrscheinlichkeit an da
die oft nicht vorhanden ist dekoriert
man gerne völlig entgegengesetzt
entscheidungskriterium erstmal auf das
vorsorgeprinzip actional principal
bestimmt sehr viel gesetzgeber und
zulassung von essen in der eu zulassung
von nahrungsmitteln umweltpolitik auch
international und das vorsorgeprinzip
ist vielleicht begrifflich notorisch
unter gestimmt in einer starken
formulierung sagt es fokussiere auf den
schlechtest möglichen ausgang und
versucht dies entgegen zu wirken oder
ihn zu vermeiden eine technik wurde auch
diese letzte formulierung stark gemacht
beispielsweise von hans jonas in seinem
prinzip verantwortung also
vorsorgeprinzip als vermeide dieses
worst case szenario das ist natürlich
etwas wo sich dann die technik tätig zu
recht vorwerfen lassen muss dass man zum
nichtstun verpflichtet das kann
natürlich auch leben also dieses prinzip
von hans jonas er spricht auch von einer
heuristik der furcht zitat der
schlechten prognose den vorrang zu geben
gegenüber der guten das ist
verantwortungsbewusstes handeln im
hinblick auf zukünftige generationen
aber dann kann man nur noch zu hause
bleiben und nichts tun wenn ich meine
wenn man jegliches risiko ausschließen
völlig recht völlig richtig es gibt
vielleicht situationen wo man genau das
machen muss wenn beispielsweise gut zu
gründe vorliegen zu glauben dass diese
technik zum ende der menschheit führen
kann
das vorsorgeprinzip ist gängiger weise
angewandt
wird und wie es nur 192 formuliert wurde
ist auch deutlich schwächer man muss da
mal so ein bisschen aufpassen was man
was man meint wenn jemand für
vorsorgeprinzip redet und das gibt nur
an dass auch unsichere vorhersagen ernst
genommen werden muss also nur weil ich
nicht weiß wie die kausal mechanismen
sind die zu einem bestimmten handlungs
ausgang führen
und nur weil ich mir unsicher bin über
die wahrscheinlichkeiten heißt das nicht
dass ich diesen unsicheren handlungs
ausgang nicht mit in die erwägungen mit
einbeziehen muss und auf diese
formulierung das ist sicherlich eine
sehr rationale art mit
wissenschaftlichen prognosen umzugehen
wissenschaftliche prognosen sind
unsicher und heute werden als beispiel
wenn tiefsee pixi mining in fitch bei
den fidschi-inseln gestoppt wird dann
tut mir das heute auch noch ganz oft
unsere kurs auf diese art ist vor so
getrennt und sie haben gesagt dieses
vorsorgeprinzip wir sind in der politik
fest verankert also so wie in der
schweiz in deutschland die eu sogar in
der uno etwa wenn man einen begründeten
verdacht hat um ein produkt vom markt zu
nehmen dann dann reicht das schon man
muss kein nachweis führen dass wäre
tagen ein beispiel dafür
und trotzdem jetzt hat man diese zwei
prinzipien dass eine sozusagen vermeidet
ein worst case sage ich jetzt mal ganz
einfach gesagt etwas anderes den
mittelwert zu nehmen und dann irgendwie
die bestmögliche option die haben
wenigstens risiko birgt sich dafür zu
entscheiden
und jetzt muss man ja trotzdem sich
überlegen wie man in der konkreten
situation nach welches prinzip man sich
stützt und und wie man entscheidet das
braucht wohl gar nicht so etwas wie die
urteilskraft wie macht man das genau
also vielleicht doch noch mal gut zu
wenn und ich meine männer feld ist ein
ganzes spektrum was die beiden extreme
auf ok das gibt dann mathematisch zum
teil sehr aufwändig verfeinerungen der
das risiko prinzips und auch noch
verfeinerungen das vorsorgeprinzip
aber was sie richtig sagen die
eigentlich grundsätzliche ethische frage
die sich der entscheidende
ingenieurstellen muss aber vielleicht
auch in bestimmten situationen der
politiker ist bei welcher art der
handlung also bei welcher art der
vorhergesagten folgende welcher
von wissen muss ich denn welches
prinzipien ergreifen und da sagen diese
konzeptionen erstmal nichts dazu und ich
denke auch dass der rekurs auf seine ja
eher aus der tugend et kommen der
urteilskraft also eine ja erst mal
verstanden dass so eine art charakter
eine eigenschaft die man eine haltung
die man trainieren kann
die erstmal eine verstandes tugend ist
also eine intellektuelle tugend aber
immer auf das moralisch gute gerichtet
könnte dabei helfen also wir kennen so
was ein wenig aus der modernen kann so
ein revival der tugend attack seit mitte
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts aber das
sind eher klassische gedanken aus der
aus der antike die einem hier vielleicht
helfen können
ja diese genuin modernen probleme im
umgang mit großtechnischen systemen und
risiken umzugehen also das ganze geht
zurück auf aristoteles der in seiner
schrift die komischen dem ikonische
ethik ich dafür plädiert dass das dass
eine tugend eine haltung ist also nicht
so sehr auf die einzelne handlung ein
mann kommt sondern dass man irgend ein
guter mensch wird und dann auch diese
urteilskraft hat um im einzelnen moment
entscheiden zu können eine ärztin zum
beispiel kann dann irgendwie entscheiden
welche welche therapie richtig ist und
welche eingriffe richtig ist und das
handbuch würde das noch offen ließ das
braucht viel erfahrung
nach der führung konkret zu entscheiden
interessant finde ich bei ihnen sie
unterrichten ja in karlsruhe und und da
auch jongleure und leiten derzeit eine
akademie für verantwortungsvolle
forschung lehre und innovation also
bilden sozusagen sind für die ethische
ausbildung der erste höhere zuständig
sag ich jetzt mal so müssen einfach
gesagt was bringen sie den den denn bei
und welche welches selbstverständnis aus
akteure haben die also ich glaube die
meisten jungen leute sondern dazu
gehören auch den studierenden sind heute
ganz anders für ethische themen
sensibilisiert auch in der eigenen
arbeit als das vielleicht jetzt noch vor
20 30 jahren der fall war
was uns wichtig ist den ingenieuren
nicht einfach ethische theorie
beizubringen ich glaube das ist schon
wichtig und so würden die meisten tun
meisten leute die heute die tugend ethik
stark machen in der an
eine ethik verstehen die tugend ethik
entweder als ergänzung oder vielleicht
auch fast als instrument ell wertvoll
zur umsetzung von futuristischen
konzeptionen lux nähte konzessionen oder
ähnlichem
und so sehen wir das auch also was wir
gute technik in einem ethischen sinn
gute technik die bedarf natürlich
bestimmte rechtliche rahmenbedingungen
gehabt bestimmte regularien das darf man
auch nicht vergessen die in deutschland
beispielsweise für ein für deutsche
ingenieure macht die dänen die iso
normen usw aber gleichzeitig lässt sich
gute techniken nicht an einem
kriterienkatalog abarbeiten auch nicht
an ethischen theorien
denn zum einen muss man ja es ist ein
gewisses forschung es gibt prospektiv
neue dinge die man nicht von vornherein
regeln kann also stellen sie sich vor
was in der zeit von christa karas
wir wollen ja angewandte wissenschaftler
die sensibilisiert sind dass so eine
gehen schere vielleicht ethische
probleme haben könnte dies vielleicht
nicht bis ins letzte detail durchdenken
müssen aber so eine art moralischer
kompass und sowas könnte so diese
urteilsfähigkeit leisten und moralischen
kompass zu haben müssten sie noch zwei
sätze du zu dieser gegen schere
großbäckers sagen und was da die risiken
wären genau also es ist eine möglichkeit
relativ gezielt und das erbgut
einzugreifen damit natürlich auch für
mehrere generationen das erbgut zu
verändern auch von lebenden organismen
gab letztes jahr den ja letztes jahr den
arm chemienobelpreis dafür ein sehr
wertvolles werkzeug mit unglaublichen
potenzial für die medizinische forschung
auch aber natürlich auch mit mit
problemen
das ehrt einen philosophisch interessant
ist natürlich die frage ob es
irgendwelche stopps geben muss für die
forschung also denken wir an ein stein
zurück mit der atombombe der irgendwie
mit seiner relativitätstheorie die
grundlagen für einerseits kernkraft aber
für die atombombe natürlich gelegt hat
zeigt die ambivalenz der technik aber
auch die verantwortung die mit wissen
einhergeht und die macht die man mit
wissen hat gibt es denn aus ihrer sicht
gute gründe wo man sagen kann da sollte
man die forschung stoppen
ja ich glaube diese liegen jetzt
vielleicht anders als
als meinem fall von christa karas ich
glaube es gibt bestimmte fragen haben
die wir uns aus der überlegung heraus
wie wir unsere gesellschaft leben wollen
nicht stellen sollten
das betrifft fragen zur unterschiede
zwischen menschen denke ich vielleicht
jetzt viel stärker als dieses wir können
jetzt nicht in bestimmte wissensbereiche
vor und dringen dass man sich bestimmt
die frage gar nicht stellen so habe ich
das richtig verstanden
ja also wenn bestimmte fragen als
schlicht und ergreifend im widerspruch
sind zudem wie wir unsere demokratische
gesellschaftsordnung leben wollen also
wir gehen ja von der gleichheit aller
menschen aus dann ist das natürlich sehr
problematisch dass in studien zu
hinterfragen die natürlich auch gemacht
werden auch was wäre konkret so eine
frage ob es unterschiede zwischen den
zwischen menschen unterschiedlicher
hautfarbe in bezug auf relevante
eigenschaften unserer gesellschaft gibt
intelligenz zweiter sekretär würden sie
sagen das sollte man gar nicht ein
forschungsprojekt dazu nutzen sie also
ich würde mir ich würde mir wünschen
dass eine ethikkommission das sehr genau
hinschaut und da gerade also die
forschungsfrage die ich jetzt als
beispiel formuliert habe natürlich auch
mit grossen unsicherheiten verbunden ist
also wenn das jetzt durch exerziert ja
intelligenz ist eine schwer messbar das
konzept das die operationelle sicherung
von spielerischem halt immer bloß eine
kleine auswahl der bevölkerungsgruppe
wenn ich jetzt die die weißen
nobelpreisträger
menschen aus einer sozial
benachteiligten schichten nehme und die
dunkelhäutigen nobelpreis treibt
griechen anderes ergebnis raus als wenn
ich den max anders anschaue da würde ich
mir wünschen dass eine ethikkommission
sehr genau hinschaut oder wir vielleicht
auf solche fragen als gesellschaft gar
nicht stellen wollen
also anderen dingen wie quest pack s da
ist es ja so dann muss ich auch den
wissenschaftlern da verstehe ich auch
die wissenschaftler im englischen sind
science dass naturwissenschaftler diesen
diesem wissen streep und diese diese
fokus drauf was als was gut ist raus
kommen könnte ich glaube dual use
problematik ist natürlich immer da nicht
nur jungs heißt so zu sagen man hat ich
habe hier so ein hammer dabei ist ein
werkzeug das kann man jetzt den kann man
dazu verwenden anlagen zu schlagen das
ist sehr nützlich aber ich kann auch
jemand sozusagen den kopf einschlagen
mit diesem ding also eine these könnte
man sagen technik ist immer neutral
es kommt darauf an was man damit macht
auf die auf die anwendung aber so leicht
ist es glaube ich ja auch nicht ich
glaube als julius problematik ist
natürlich ganz klar nicht nur bei diesen
klassischen dingen wie atomenergie auch
zum beispiel groß rechnungs
rechenzentren ja also es gibt einen
atomwaffentest start vertrag
aber natürlich werden atomwaffen
getestet das werden sie auch computer
und handy laufen an den großen auf den
großen rechenzentren also auch bei
rechenzentren hat man eine dual use
problematik aber ich glaube der großzahl
oder die der großteil der technik quelle
auch in der im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
ganz stark mit der umweltethik verbunden
war befasst sich gar nicht damit eine
neutrale technik führenden verwerfliches
ziel zu gebrauchen sondern mit den er
mit den nebenwirkungen des gut nur
zumindest ethischen neutralen gebrauchs
ein beispiel fukushima risikostufe dabei
spiele auch die kontinuierliche
nebenwirkungen zb co2 emissionen bei der
verbrennung fossiler energieträger und
da gibt es auch dieses phänomen dass
technik so eine eigendynamik annehmen
kann und nicht mehr so ist dass wir
sozusagen die technik aus mittel zum
zweck benutzen sondern die technik gegen
wir uns uns benutzen uns verändert unser
erleben unser zeitgefühl also ein
die zum beispiel was das alles mit uns
machen das macht uns auch abhängig
natürlich verändert unsere routine
unsere lebensgewohnheiten unsere art wie
wir die welt sehen
das hat 88 auch die eisenbahn auch im
flugzeug die distanzen
es gibt ja diese lange technik kritische
tradition in der in der philosophie von
russo bis bis zu heidecke von
entfremdung bei marx zum beispiel dass
sich technik uns irgendwie entfremdet
von der natur
da war von von uns selbst ist dass in
der modernen technik philosophie noch
ein thema gibt es dann auch so zu sagen
die optimisten und die pessimisten oder
ist das alles
ich glaube nicht ich glaube die technik
philosophie ihm ähnlich wie die
wissenschaft philosophie hat im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert also ich hab den
diese moderne art der technik tätig
beginnt wirklich mit den in den 60er
jahren mit mit auch der umwelt also das
sind auch so bücher wie silent spring
von wacker ist ein klassisches umwelt
ethisches buch sehr einschlägig gewesen
in der zwischenzeit hat die technik
attica zwei praxis wenden gemacht und
versucht sich heute abend das eine die
erste praxis wende war zu erkennen dass
das handeln des ingenieurs wirklich im
detail des technikers im detail wert ist
sozialwissenschaftler philosophisch
untersucht zu werden da gab es eine
ganze neue disziplin nicht
herausgesprungen ist
sts social studies social ist jetzt
social studies of technology das 1 1
sein technology studies und dann gab es
innerhalb der philosophie der technik
noch die zweite praxis wende dass man
sich versucht tatsächlich frühzeitig in
den technik entwicklungs diskurs
einzuschalten
dass man nicht versucht im nachhinein zu
sagen das war eine blöde idee das wurde
ja wirklich lange zeit der technik
philosophie vorgeworfen wir hatten es ja
gerade schon eine verbots ethik das
positive des technischen handels wird
überhaupt nicht gewürdigt und
gleichzeitig rückwärts gewandt
am abend wenn dann schon gelaufen das
klassisches philosophisches problem
und das versucht man heutzutage zu
vermeiden und man versucht sich mit
verschiedensten arten dann frühzeitig in
den technik entwicklung einzuschalten zu
zeitpunkten im technologischen
designprozess nur noch dinge wohl auch
verschiedene weichen gestellt werden
können wie wachen sie ist krank ganz
konkret jetzt an einem beispiel
vielleicht in karlsruhe neue technologie
wo sie sagen jetzt müssen wir die
sozusagen in den startlöchern und jetzt
schon die ethikerin untätige ich nehme
beispiel aus der vergangenheit weil das
glaube ich ganz gut deutlich macht was
man macht negatives beispiel was man
anders machen hätte können
es gibt ein konzept gibt viele konzepte
und ein konzept ist sehr bekannt ist
nennt sich wehrte sensibles design
values and if design und die
grundlegende idee dahinter ist wirklich
in den frühen entwicklungsphasen sich
bewusst welche ethischen werte vertreten
werden welches stakeholder da sind die
in den diskurs mit einzubeziehen und das
ganze dann in technische produkte
umzusetzen das ganze nicht interaktiv
sondern wirklich ineinander gekoppelt
verzahnt und springt wieder zurück von
der konzeptionellen von der von der
empirischen ebene die die stakeholder
befragt wieder zu konzeptionellen ebene
also beide beim produktionsprozess bei
der innovation schon so sagen die
ethischen werte im blick zu haben und da
auch die betroffenen von dieser technik
genau genau und dass das in enger
verzahnung mit den mit denen die technik
entwickeln und das negativbeispiel ich
habe das tatsächlich jetzt nicht aus
gaza sondern von der tu delft
da wurde das dann eingeführt im design
department und sie hatten ganz kurz
davor eine entwicklung gemacht solar
solar betrieben
maschinen für die näherinnen in
bangladesch und indien
niedriglohnbereich damit die flexibel
sind und nicht in diesen schlechten ein
bisschen schlechten baulichen
bedingungen arbeiten müssen also
wirklich sehr gutes ziel haben das
resultat dieser innovation war was die
frauen zu hause arbeiten mussten weil
sie ihre männer gar nicht mehr in die
öffentlichkeit gelassen haben sie
konnten jetzt zu hause arbeiten also
genau an sehr sehr negativer effekt für
die beteiligten frauen und hätte man
dieses konzept des wallis nzf designs
angewandt wer relativ schnell klar
geworden dass die relevanten stakeholder
und deswegen hab ich das beispiel
gewöhnt erwähnt auch weißen auch wenn es
ein negatives ist weil hier die
stakeholder so schon abgegrenzt und klar
sind die stakeholder dem falls sind teil
ganz klar die frauen die diese
technologie benutzen und hätte man die
irgendwie involviert wäre es hat zu der
fehlentwicklung gar nicht gekommen
[Musik]
lassen sie uns machen müssen
zurückkommen zur energie und zur zukunft
der energieversorgung
wir hatten fukushima erwähnt wer jetzt
die frage wie wir eigentlich eine
zukunft gehen und ob wir auf diese
risiken der kernenergie verzichten
können ich glaube es gibt ja eine
moderne technik philosophie den öko
modernismus der sagt nein wir brauchen
diese kernenergie auch angesichts des
klimawandels von bill gates ist kein
neues buch erschienen der auch in diese
richtung geht weil die kernenergie hat
nicht klimaschädlich ist was halten sie
denn von dieser von dieser haltung oder
von dieser einschätzung bezüglich
kernkraft ich muss ehrlich sein ich
teile die relativ uneingeschränkt ich
habe momentan das gefühl wir haben mit
der betreibt mit dem treibhauseffekt
einer globalen erwärmung in vor uns
liegen dass wirkliches problem und wir
laufen auf den abgrund zu und hoffen
dass damit erneuerbaren energien
irgendwann mal netz sich auftaucht und
gleichzeitig haben wir eine eine
verlotterte brücke bei der wir
vielleicht wenn wir darüber gehen auch
noch irgendjemandem geld geben müssen
dem wir kein geld geben wollen aber wir
haben diese folge und das ist für mich
die kernenergie
ich glaube dass gut daran getan ist
alles immer neue viel in die entwicklung
von erneuerbaren zu stärken ich sehe
aber nicht dass das unser problem löst
aber unabhängig davon glaube ich ist der
elefant im raum über energie reden die
energie ist ändert die einsparung gerade
im westen in den entwickelten ländern
ist schon im rest der welt ganz ganz
anders aus aber wir haben den elefant im
raum und darüber redet niemand alles was
ich gerade gesagt wir weniger energie
brauchen so dass wir weniger energie
brauchen sollten das was ich gerade
gesagt habe über die kernenergie und
dieses diesen abgrund auf denen wir zu
laufen in freudiger erwartung dass sich
alle übertragungs und alle speicher
probleme gelöst haben betrifft natürlich
nur den fall dass das energie der
energieverbrauch so steigt wir gerade zu
steigen also sie haben zwei bilder
wir haben den abgrund wir reden darauf
zu es gibt ein schlechtes netz das uns
nicht tragen wir die erneuerbaren allein
es gibt daneben eine riskante brücke die
uns besser würden sie sagen das ist der
atomkraft im moment so lange die energie
die die erneuerbaren nicht weiter sind
wir noch so viel energie verbrauchen
sollten wir über diese brücke gegeben
vielleicht hält uns das netz
technologiesprünge kann man schwierig
vorhersagen ich würde sagen auch da wo
wir stehen sehen wir gerade kein netz
mehr fantasie in rees gerade her
natürlich ist es viel getan und ziel
auch an primärenergie leistung ist
unglaublich gestiegen als die
erneuerbaren angeht aber das
speicherproblem wurde uns auf absehbare
zeit begleiten und ich glaube dass die
öko modernisten was hier einleiten
gesagt haben deutlich machen es dass
eine sichere und preiswerte
energieversorgung viele andere
ökologische probleme lösen könnte also
wir haben genug wasser auf dem planeten
nur leider in der form von salzwasser
das lässt sich in trinkwasser umwandeln
halt nur sehr energieintensiv recycling
alles sehr sehr energieaufwendige
prozesse das heißt ich glaube wenn der
energiefrage mal beantwortet ist
vielleicht mit erneuerbaren das glaube
ich kann man muss jetzt noch nicht
absehen ob das wirklich realistisch ist
und sicherlich nicht auf die zeitspannen
die deutsche bundesregierung bis mitte
des jahrhunderts an legt man muss sich
auch bewusst machen dass die
machbarkeitsstudien ökonomische
machbarkeitsstudien sind keine
technischen
ja dann wenn das wenn energie vorhanden
ist mit erneuerbaren oder mit
kernenergie lassen sich viele andere
ökologischen probleme lösen oder
erscheinen nicht mehr so gravierend
bleiben mir immer noch bei den problemen
der erneuerbaren also die speicherung
haben sie angesprochen ist scheint das
haupt eines der hand probleme zu sein
also beispiel dafür ist bei
sonnenenergie im winter dies hat weniger
da und dann gibt es sozusagen loch dann
hätten wir keine energie im winter oder
das risiko wer da und jetzt wäre
sozusagen die atomkraft eine so etwas
wie ein rückfall option in diesen
löchern niveau zu wenig erneuerbare
hätten das wäre ein vorschlag wie wir
sozusagen für die nächsten jahre
das wäre zum beispiel eine option also
diese diese backup kraftwerke was wir
gerade fossil machen das über die
kernenergie zu machen ich glaube auch
dass der diskurs zum beispiel für ein
land wie deutschland der schweiz das
sicherlich noch anders aus der diskurs
zu spät kommt also da ist
da wird alles rückgebaut und die
ökonomischen kosten
ich fokussiere mich natürlich auch bis
gerade auf einen teil der debatte auf
die ökologischen aspekte und da muss man
auch immer sagen ja auch grüne
technologien haben probleme also man
kann da jetzt beliebig plakative
beispiele nennen also die onshore
windanlagen zu die am land stehen sind
in deutschland den konservativsten
schätzungen nach für 25.000 tote
fledermäuse pro jahr verantwortlich
die fliegen durch die sehen die
rotorblätter und denn das sind ja auch
säugetiere den zerreißt die lungen
aufgrund des unter druck weil die
rotorblätter so schnell rotieren andere
nennt das gerne auch green green
konflikts andere konflikte kennt man
auch bei der batterieentwicklung gerade
bei dem ganzen zwischen grünen und
grünen sozusagen ökologie gegen ökologie
wir haben dass sich das problem mit den
stauseen in der schweiz wie hoch dürfen
diese ein zum beispiel und dann ist noch
das akzeptanzproblem auch bei den
windrädern also die anliegen der
bevölkerung möchte das ja in der regel
nicht
da glaube ich kann man noch da könnte
man auch noch in
dinge dazu sagen also gerade in
deutschland
ich kenne vielleicht auch vielleicht
auch weiterhin deutschen diskurs besser
kennen wird dann immer auf dieses von
politischer seite aber auch von
denjenigen die die technik umsetzen
wollen gerne auf das nimm befinden wenn
rekurriert und nimm die not in my
backyard ich bin für grüne technologie
ich bin für windenergie aber bitte nicht
bei mir bitte nicht in meinem hinterhof
not in my backyard und ja und das was
wird seit den 80er jahren als die
monstranz vor sich hergetragen warum die
umsetzung bestimmter technologien die
eigentlich als gut erkannt werden
schwierig ist und jetzt gibt es seit
frei zu 15 20 jahren
sozialwissenschaftliche studien zu
solchen standortfragen und die zeigen
eigentlich alle unisono dass es eben
nicht so ist wie dieses nominal liegt
dass die leute egoistisch sind die im
widerstand aktiv sind und uninformiert
sondern eher im gegenteil die mahnen an
dass relevante werte nicht
berücksichtigt wurden und ganz oft geht
es hier aber auch nicht nur aber auch um
prozedurale werte transparenz der
entscheidungsfindung wird wird bemängelt
dass die leute nicht eingebunden werden
ich meine wer diesen erneuerbaren stellt
sich erst problem wie wie groß macht man
aus also in diese windräder kann man
natürlich im norden gibt es mehr wind im
süden gibt es mehr sonne
man müsste das problem wahrscheinlich
auch eher europäisch denken aus national
das auf alle fälle was sieht man also
gerade ich glaube es hat vielleicht
jetzt viele in den medien gesehen vor
ein paar wochen in texas viel von der
stromversorgung zusammengebrochen ist
das war ja auch ein resultat von einem
staat der sich autark aufstellen wollte
jetzt haben wir über die energiewende im
schnelldurchlauf gesprochen vielleicht
können sie nochmal sagen wo sie die
großen führten sie in nahrungs so
langsam geht auch wenn wir nochmal
zurückdenken an dieses vorsorgeprinzip
also sie haben jetzt gesagt wir brauchen
die die kernkraft sozusagen als rückfall
option das ist diese brücke
wir haben wir im moment nicht aber man
könnte natürlich auch sagen wenn wir an
zion als ernst nehmen dieses
vorsorgeprinzip die
schlechten folgen da haben wir die
unfallrisiken der ak w s wir haben das
endlagerung problem montiert müsste ja
ist so schnell wie möglich da raus und
egal was es kostet irgendwie mehr
verzichten und so weiter einfach mit
anderen anderen weg wer aber ich glaube
gleichzeitig muss man auch sagen das war
dass man verwende ich vorsorgeprinzip an
risiko wie weit will ich mal ein
entscheidungs horizont und wenn ich bei
der entscheidung gegen die kernenergie
auch mit berücksichtigt die negativen
effekten der alternativen
energieversorgung oder stromerzeugung
methoden sprich fossile noch dann ist
das schon nicht mehr ganz so klar wie es
mit dem klima wie sonst schaut genau und
der mit seinen negativen effekten
vielleicht vergleichbar ist einem einem
nuklearen endlager ich vermute also
meine meine einschätzung ist dass da die
probleme deutlich größere sind und wenn
wir noch mehr geld und energie in die
erneuerbaren und lief in die forschung
stecken würden sicherlich eine gute idee
mehr mehr geld in forschung und
entwicklung zu stecken
aber ich glaube das grundlegende problem
ist tatsächlich ein nicht technisches
und das bringt wieder zu dem zu dem
punkt dass energie das energiesparen
sich glaubt den den lebensstandard den
wir von energetischer seite im westen
auch in europa nicht nur in amerika an
den kammern weltweit nicht halten
also es geht an energie spannung an
unsere überdenken des lebensstils nichts
dran vorbei so ist eine um den verzicht
kommen wir nicht herum
ja ich hab's ja aber wie wir sind ich
würde da hab ich nicht mehr unbedingt
verzichten und ich glaube man kann ja
auch noch mal ein schritt zurücktreten
und sich zu fragen was worin besteht
eigentlich lebensqualität und
wohlergehen und brauchen wir dazu
überhaupt all diese optionen es gibt ja
meistens verschiedene wege wie man das
gleiche erreicht und natürlich die
energie werden das momentan vor allem
eine strom wende wir haben in geringem
umfang mobilitäts wende
wir haben auch noch den wärmesektor wo
die wende noch gar nicht so angekommen
ist und man kann die hoffnung haben dass
wenn man all diese sektoren noch stärker
koppelt gerade auch mit der
digitalisierung des stromnetzes dass das
energien erreicht werden aber am strom
und global zumindest
es sind alle studien davon ausgehen dass
wir die welt bevölkern oder ob es teile
derselben durch erneuerbare versorgen
können komplett gehen vom starken
geringeren pro kopf energie verbrauchen
schauen wir mal kurz stand heute in der
schweiz habe ich habe zwei grafiken
vorbereitet die eine grafik zeigt den
verbrauch nach energieträgern das
irgendwie dass nur ein viertel knapp ein
viertel des verbrauchs aus der energie
kommt aus erneuerbaren jetzt in der
schweiz und der rest drei viertel aus
nicht erneuerbaren quellen beim bei der
produktion in der schweiz sieht ein
bisschen anders aus die schweiz
profitiert stark von wasserkraft aber
auch hier 40 prozent im wesentlichen ist
das atomkraft und nur sechs prozent
erneuerbare also da muss noch sehr viel
passieren
sie sagen sagen aber auch die politik
trifft derzeit auch krasse
fehlentscheidung zb werden dinge
gefördert die einfach nicht gefördert
werden sollen zum beispiel der
individualverkehr also dass man darf
electro hat das umstellt warum ist das
unsinn aus ihrer sicht habe ich war
vorhin ja sehr vorsichtig habe gesagt ja
bei der energieversorgung alles sehr
komplexen wir sind bei ethischen im
ethischen graubereich unterwegs aber ich
glaube gerade der individualverkehr ist
etwas was glaube ich in der nachhaltigen
energiezukunft als der wenigen dinge
glaube ich den nachhaltigen
energiezukunft wirklich keinen platz
haben wir es einfach zu energieintensiv
ist
ich glaube es wird immer randgruppen
geben die auf den individualverkehr
angewiesen sind behinderte vielleicht
aber der großteil der bevölkerung muss
sich an ein
und da ist die lösung eben auch eine art
zumindestens nicht ich keine heitzig
lösung und auch nur bedingten technische
lösungen nicht technisierten muss
fortbewegungsmitteln zu widmen oder dem
öffentlichen nahverkehr
ich glaube nicht dass damit die
elektromobilität überhaupt keinen platz
mehr hat aber nicht aus autos die für
mich oder meine familie sind sondern die
werden verschwinden müssten weil ich sie
richtig verstehe also zumindest mit
benzin oder mit strom
genau weil sie haben
der strommix gesehen auch mein auto auch
wenn dann irgendwie die die verbrennung
woanders statt wenn wird eine
innenstädte sauber bleiben der
energieverbrauch bleibt der gleiche
und wir haben beim auto natürlich immer
das problem egal wie es ausschaut dass
wir ein mobiles speichermedium brauchen
sei es eine batterie mit all den
problemen die die haben sehr
energieintensiv in der herstellung ist
eiswasser stoffe werden immer
energieintensive speichermedien
gebrauchen aber wie bringt man die
bevölkerung dahin dass sie sich gegen
die autos entscheiden das ist eine gute
frage und das ist natürlich auch das
muss ich dafür so wenn man so gern
zurück zieht und sagt na das ist die
politische aufgabe die auf fragen für
die soziologen aber ich glaube es ist
eine langsame entscheidung und gerade in
deutschland ist natürlich die förderung
des elektro verkehrs gar nicht mal
ausland aus liebe zum auto geschuldet
sondern einfach sehr liebe zu den
arbeitsplätzen also das ist ja irgendwie
und vielleicht wenn man die dinge beim
namen nennen würde dass es um
arbeitsplätze geht und nicht um die
förderung der automobilindustrie mit
ihren zulieferern
wer glaube ich ein potenzial gegeben um
probleme anzugehen
also an transparenz aber das wäre eine
revolution also das führte schon wie
bedeutend die ganze autoindustrie
abzuschaffen in den nächsten jahrzehnten
ja nicht klappt so ein langer prozess
ist mir auch erst vor kurzem klar
geworden dass das endziel zu dem man hin
will dieser transformationsprozess haben
und redete ja nicht umsonst von von
transformationen immer mehr auch in der
in der sozialwissenschaftlichen
reflexion auf technik die können ja
vielleicht oder müssen vielleicht
anderen kriterien genügen als das
endziel wo man hin will
aber ja ich glaube und ich glaube die
transparenz ist vielleicht auch eine
haben nicht nur eine in der
kommunikation sondern auch sich selber
überhaupt bewusst zu werden warum
förderlich oder warum bin ich gerade
stehe ich gerade für irgendetwas 1
sie selbst haben keine alter nehme ich
hab jetzt endlich so lassen sie uns
gegen ende des gesprächs noch in die
zukunft schauen welche neuen technologie
entstehen so am horizont
aus ihrer sicht und welche gefahren sind
damit verbunden sie war vielleicht
nehmen sie ein oder zwei hauskreis was
die nächsten jahrzehnte auf uns zukommen
also mindestens energiebereich bleiben
dann ist natürlich technologien die
immer die auch woanders aber auch im
technologie energiebereich wichtig
werden ist natürlich kaffee und die
digitalisierung noch allgemeiner und die
ist natürlich auch ethisch heraus also
für poetische herausfordernd also
natürlich eine ganz andere dynamik in
den sektor bringt das ist für die indus
beteiligten industrien eine
herausforderung aber auch für die
ethische bewertung energiesektor mann
mann hatten an man hat eine kraftwerk
gehabt man stellt das 25 jahre hin dass
mindestens die schweizer kernkraftwerke
laufen 50 jahre zum teil plus man hat
netzwerk installiert für große zeiträume
digitalisierung bringt auch eine ganz
andere dynamik und auch ganz andere
ethische herausforderungen ich glaube
hier ist vor allem und ich denke auch
beim autonomen fahren vor allem
datensicherheit vorher man kann sehr
sehr viel informationen über das
individuum ablesen dass das eine und das
andere ist denke ich auch die
engineering weil ich glaube wir werden
probleme laufen mit dem klimawandel
das sehen wir jetzt schon ziemlich
deutlich als und nicht merken nicht mehr
am horizont hat relativ deutlichen auch
vor ort und in anderen ländern gerade
monsun regionen ist das ganze ja noch
viel schlimmer aus wir haben ein genie
ring haben sie gesagt was wäre ein
beispiel das also dass das wohl plakativ
sste war ich bin auch umstrittenste
beispiel das einbringen von sulfat euro
sollen in die atmosphäre
also im endeffekt man das ist jetzt sehr
plakative oder sehr verkürzt dargestellt
man versucht eine kühlung der atmosphäre
zu erreichen so ähnlich wie man das bei
einem vulkanausbruch hat und da wurde
jetzt erst im februar ein experiment
genehmigt in den
wissenschaftler der harvard universität
ein experiment starten in schweden im
juni diesen jahres und momentan also ist
nicht ganz klar ob das durchgehen wird
weil momentan sehr viele umweltverbände
sicherlich auch aus guten gründen
es gibt auch viel dafür zu sein und fiel
dagegen zu sagen momentan dagegen
demonstrieren weil es eben als dammbruch
entsenden
und vielleicht das erwachen kommt da
etwas in die atmosphäre dieses sofa oder
genauer o sohle einfach gehen und die
soll das irgendwie kühlen und ins und
dann langfristig den klimawandel
de facto also mann hatte man hat ja
historische kühlungen der atmosphäre
gehabt durch starke vulkanausbrüche
bekannt wurde sondern richtig durch
so ähnlich kann man sich das vorstellen
und ich glaube so glaube ich viel
gewonnen wäre es wenn man solche
experimente macht solche techniken
entwickelt ohne dass gleich klar ist es
ist viel geld reingesteckt worden und
deswegen wenden wir sie an dass man
wirklich auch schon im vornherein so
stoppt punkte ich glaube sie hätten von
einer richtung glaube ich eher werden
stoppen sich überlegt bei denen man
vielleicht nicht notwendigerweise sagt
und jetzt nicht weiter aber zumindestens
sagt und das ist ein kritischer punkt
den wir als ja real realer weltliches
experiment anschauen müssen ob wir das
ganze noch mal überdenken müssen sie hat
das ist und das kommt dieses real
weltliche experiment also weil bei all
diesen großen technologien ist ja die
ganze gesellschaft irgendwie zu einem
labor und wird würde danach betroffen
sein in einem fall bei bei fukushima hat
man dass man was gesehen aber bei diesem
neuen geo engineering zum beispiel auch
und da stellt sich natürlich auch die
frage wie man eine demokratische
legitimierung hinkriegt wie man die
bevölkerung mit ins boot nimmt ob die
ein vetorecht haben ob die zustimmen
müssen bei solchen sachen
was gibt es eine antwort dazu ich glaube
es ist sehr sehr schwierig weil man
natürlich immer gerne drauf rekord
zurückfallen kann dass es zu schwierig
ist diese abschätzung an die
allgemeinheit zu überlassen aber ich
glaube der weg ist tatsächlich nicht
also den ich jetzt auf meiner
persönlichen erfahrung
dass man stärker dahin geht die
bevölkerung partizipativ mitzunehmen
und ich glaube dass es konkrete
transparenz also transparenz und heißt
in dem fall auch gut so methoden der
wissenschaftskommunikation dass die
relevanten fakten auch ohne studium der
klimawissenschaften verständlich sind
forschung in richtung mögliche folgen
das ist ja nichts was man mal aus dem
bauch heraus entscheidet welche richtung
das dagegen kann und das dann gut
kommunizieren
wer dann die relevanten stakeholder sind
es ist das eine nationale entscheidung
von schweden oder müssen die harvard
wissenschaftler insbesondere weil sie
die experten sind besondere entscheidung
was weiß ich fünfmal gewichtet werden
pro person in ihren entscheidungen
es ist schwierig zu sagen und ich glaube
transparenz ist wichtig ja jetzt hatten
wir ganz am anfang über diese tugend
ethik noch gesprochen dass man sozusagen
wenn es darum geht wie entscheide ich
konkret in einer situation wenn risiken
bestehen bei möglichen optionen können
sie vielleicht zum schluss der sendung
also eine faustregel mitgeben für uns
als individuen wie wir
egal ob das irgendwie große politische
entscheide sind sie mit risiken
verbunden sind ob wir die neue
technologien fördern sorgen oder nicht
ob wir gentechnik fördern sondern oder
nicht aber auch im alltag wie wir mit
risiken umgehen sollten wie wie gehen
sie durchs leben prägen also ich glaub
ich nicht eine faustregel vielleicht
eher 3 also es gibt es gibt
untersuchungen dazu welche wahrnehmungs
verzerrungen es menschen obliegen gerade
bei entscheidungen unter unsicherheiten
also das kennt ja jeder wenn gerade ein
flugzeug runtergefallen dass man stark
ins flugzeug dann hat jeder mehr angst
als normal
diese juristisch an bayers das lied
wörter oder diese diese heuristiken und
vorurteile an sich bewusst zu werden und
das zweite ist auf das bauchgefühl zu
hören und nicht als handlungsleitend
sondern wenn ich mit meinem bauchgefühl
über irgendwas
unbehagen hat dem nachzugehen und
nachzugehen mit wissenschaftlichen
informationen ist das halt wurde ist das
nicht also ich glaube bauchgefühl als
handlungsleitend das problematisch aus
einer hand wirklich gar keinen anderen
anhaltspunkt wir sind als menschen die
gut mit unsicherheiten umzugehen werden
als spezies überhaupt nicht überlebt
wenn ihr das nicht könnten und diese
engführung rationales entscheidendes
immer das was den erwarteten nutzen
maximiert ist nicht sehr hilfreich weil
wir ja meistens diese
wahrscheinlichkeiten gar nicht zur
verfügung haben aber damit irgendwie
umgehen können und das irgendwie ist
auch ein auftrag an die forschung zu
versuchen das besser abzubilden dass wir
es dann auch besser in den politischen
entscheidungsfindungsprozesse kopieren
können
also einerseits auf das bauchgefühl
vertrauen aber auch zulassen dass
möglichst viel empirie und rationalität
der einigkeit in diese intuition das ist
sozusagen ja ich denke gerade wenn es um
natur umfragen dass umweltschutz geht es
um technik geht dann ist dann sind
naturwissenschaftliche forschung dass
die informationsquelle per wahl das
gleiche gilt natürlich für medizinische
forschung frau eva braun am ende des
gesprächs vielen herzlichen dank gerne
danke ihnen ja dann klar in für das
mitdenken nächste woche spricht wolfram
eilenberger mit dem deutschen schauspiel
star lars eidinger über die welt als
große bühne und die schauspielerei als
form der selbsterkenntnis jetzt gleich
folgt das abstimmungs studio bleiben sie
also dran und einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]